Central African Republic is in the grip
of bloody conflict and as with so many
African conflicts Europe is getting
involved rebels against the government
Muslims against Christians German
Defense Minister was a Lafond ally and
fears the conflict could destabilize the
entire region I welcome the European
Union's decision to increase its
engagement in central Africa within the
context of a stronger overall Africa
concept for Africa first out investor
Central African Republic is almost twice
the size of Germany in March last year
Muslim rebels over ran the predominantly
Christian government plunging the
country into chaos France sent in troops
as it did to Mali the previous year they
took control of the airport in the
capital bongi and refugees flocked to
the site events in faraway Central
Africa have repercussions in Germany too
the implosion from the implosion of
entire communities and states always
affects us here in Europe they affect us
as a European community which is why we
have to take a clear look the whole
situation and recognize our pan European
responsibility because I'm Pearson found
voting so the Kenan so how can Berlin
support Paris which already has boots on
the ground Germany has repeatedly said
it will not send in troops but it cannot
stay out of the situation altogether one
option is to provide aircraft three
trans hours are already stationed in
Africa it would be deployment in a
crisis region but one without ground
troops remains on the soil the
government consensus is that no combat
troops should be deployed to Central
African Republic
we are already involved in the training
mission in Mali
we could imagine doing more to train
soldiers their tune was the hospital
militia xodar unbel on if Germany were
to send more troops to Mali it would
take the burden off France following a
military coup the West African country
is also on the verge of complete turmoil
for the past year a European Union
mission has been training the Malian
army the unit includes around 100
soldiers from the German armed forces
that number could be increased so there
is a need for backup in both the north
of the country and in the security
sector the reform of the Army and the
security sector has only just begun
which means it shouldn't be stopped now
in sulfon canvas yet Snitch the pocket
wanted there's only one political party
in germany that is opposed to military
action the Left Party says it is more
important to address the root cause of
the conflict opposite we just send in
the military and that will ultimately
turn into an Afghanistan situation it
starts harmlessly but 10 years down the
line were deep in a military mission the
official justification for military
action in Africa is keeping Islamist
extremists out of power that is
especially the case in Mali but there
could be something more important at
play for Germany foreign minister
frank-walter Steinmeier is keen to
strengthen ties with France and it never
hurts to lend a helping hand
you